almost two-thirds of american people
believe
china should pay reparations for the
pandemic this is a tip inside stories
nearly two thirds of america believe the
chinese regime
should pay reparations for the
destruction caused by the human
coronavirus pandemic
according to a tip poll conducted for
the center for security policy
that number rises from 63 percent to 78
percent effect
if investigations revealed that the
chinese government released the sars
kova 19 human coronavirus
on purpose uh while southerners and
midwesterners are most likely to think
that the chinese government created the
virus and is responsible for
on unleashing the pandemic people in a
more liberal northeast are the toughest
when it comes to making china
pay reparations if an investigation
reveals an accidental
release from a government lab the
american people are taking an
increasingly hard line
toward the chinese regime that's that's
some progress right there these people
are starting to realize
right yeah but you can't you can't
collect there's no way you can oh that
was my question how do you collect on
these reparations
what are you going to do collect from
them absolutely not there's no way in
the world you're going to be able to
collect from those guys so what's the
point of even running a poll like this
then
well it's good to run a poll like this
because it tells you where the pulse of
america is today
this is actually very good to see that
collecting it completely different okay
so here's another question for you to
think about
cancel debt though because the obviously
there are so many
stuff like that what if you null and
void some of those that obviously you
can't go to them and
have them pay up but how would that let
me ask you a question
you tell me what president's going to
have the audacity to do that with them
no that's a different story you tell me
what president will have the audacity
i mean so so what's going to happen is
jp morgan goldman sachs
all these big hedge funds that have
money invested in china you're killing
my
i'm going to have to do a restatement we
can't do this
so what would happen is you would have
widespread revolt which is what you had
over the tariffs but
you know um you had a guy there that as
you said
patrick he didn't he didn't need the
money so he could say whatever he wanted
i'd like to see a world pull on this
exact thing right i mean
america alone can't solve this china
issue this needs to be a collective
world
solution right so two-thirds of
americans are close to 78 percent
uh if they find out that the chinese
government released the uh kova
um on purpose i'd like to see a world
poll on this i mean what are your
thoughts on this well
look everything that we're talking about
today you can repeat the pattern
in in europe you can repeat the pattern
in asia
what you have is a slow movement towards
authoritarianism everywhere
and it really was precipitated by the
coronavirus the chronovirus is the best
you know information op that's ever been
executed
on a global basis by anybody and it was
with the um the the the full knowledge
of our our health industry uh which
includes our pharmaceutical companies
which includes the world health
organization which includes a cdc if you
look at faji's emails i mean it's all
there
it's all there it was all about
promoting the narrative that the chinese
communist party wanted
right lock down stop the coronavirus in
his tracks where's the data coming from
it comes from china
are you kidding me general spaulding
this is the personal question i was
going to ask you earlier
i assume you're getting some sort of
pushback threats uh
i am uh so the people that support me
do it um quietly
they don't do it in the open because um
you mean in the government or wherever
yeah
okay the government yeah and and then
those that used to be in the government
and there's
you know look i get um i get you know
kind of emails and messages every single
day saying you keep doing what you're
doing you're doing the right thing
but nobody's gonna come out in in in
public and
and say hey thanks you know
this is what i'm saying is really
our system is corrupt and it's cr and
because it's corrupt
the chinese communist party have taken
control because if it's corrupt
that means you can buy it and if you can
buy it who's got the most money to buy
it
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]